so yeah I'm very happy to be to be here
I'm gonna be talking for about 30
minutes and then open it up to
after that the talk is to half's the
first half is really about what is this
big data thing to educate you guys so
you are aware what big data means and
then the second half is the startup
story of cloud era how cloud that I came
to be and some lessons that I learned as
as I was founding this company so with
that said briefly about myself I got my
my bachelor's and master's from Cary
University in Egypt and then I came here
to Stanford to get my PhD and my goal
was to get my PhD from Stanford and then
go back to Egypt and each I really liked
to teach and my dad is a professor in
can university of economics he also
really likes to teach so since I was
very young he told me you gonna grow up
and you're gonna be a professor like me
and that was my goal to get the PhD and
go back to Egypt but then Stanford
corrupted me Stanford as you know is a
very intrapreneurial school yeah you
have speakers from the industry coming
in to talk all the time you have lots of
classes like this one on
entrepreneurship and and so on so I
became very curious about this
enterpreneurship thing very quickly and
that led to me actually taking a leave
of absence out of my ph.d program in
1999 and I started my first company
which was called viva smart and we were
acquired by Yahoo a year later and we
were very lucky to be acquired by Yahoo
just before the guillotine fell down
which is the explosion of the what was
the so called
internet bubble that was happening in
the late 90s and early 2000s we had just
as a point of reference we had about 20
other startups doing the same exact
thing like us and they all failed they
all shut down during this bubble
explosion was a very bad exposure
actually so we were kind of very
fortunate unlucky that that happened to
us and then my dad kept nagging me and
saying telling me hey I'm er you have to
finish your PhD and I told him that I'm
richer than you would ever be I was
already sold my company to Yahoo made
some very good money from Yahoo and he
insisted no you have to finish the PhD
so I told Yahoo I want to go back and
finish the PhD and they said okay we'll
let you go back and finish it but you
have to keep working for us it was hard
to find the professor at Stanford
willing to take me as part-time most
professor wants you
to be full-time because they're gonna be
working on many other things beside your
PhD but luckily a professor Mendham
Lowe's Mendel rosenbloom who's as you
know one of the founders of VMware and
one of the best professors and computer
science department that biased obviously
he was my advisor he took me in and I
finished my PhD with him and around
middle of 2008 and then I left Yahoo at
that time and started cloud era which I
will tell you about in the next couple
of slides but before I do that I wanted
to briefly tell you the story of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning which is one of the key things
that we are helping to enable as a
company our product is around and about
that and I'll explain what it is in a
second but these three guys obviously
they're very famous and lots of the
credit for this machine learning and AI
falls back to them and entering 1940s so
that's 65 years ago he came up with the
Turing test which many of you would know
as one of the very first tests to check
whether we have built something as smart
as a human and the idea there was to
have two rooms one room has a computer
running AI the other room has a human
and he cannot see which room has which
and he's talking with them and he cannot
tell and that's kind of when we achieved
intelligence John McCarthy and Marvin
Minsky and they kind of coined the term
artificial intelligence and Joe McCarthy
he came up with the Lisp programming
language one of the very first symbolic
languages for artificial intelligence
and Marvin Minsky Marvin Minsky actually
came up in again again we're talking
about 50 in the 50s so that's 60 years
ago came up with the first neural
networks that actually work and you hear
all this hype about deep learning and
neural networks that was already
demonstrated many many years ago but in
the 80s a the AI winter hit we had this
AI winter were all the funding from the
u.s. from Japan all of the research
stopped in AI it just completely stopped
and it kind of died AI research died and
then if you roll forward to today we
have AI around us coming back everywhere
we have machine learning algorithms
coming around us everywhere we
the assistants like Siri and Google and
Alexa that we can converse with we have
real-time translation and Skype and
Google that can translate better than we
can as humans we have facial detection
in Facebook that again can do facial
detection quicker and faster than we can
and then we have these deep learning new
network algorithms like alphago that can
not only beat the best go players in the
world but come up with new techniques
that the go players are learning from
the machine how to play the game in a
better way so the question that I'm
gonna ask you and I'm hoping a couple of
you here can give some answers and I
have three answers to that question is
why why is machine learning coming back
why is AI becoming more feasible and
doable and happening today so just raise
your hand and say something all the way
in the back yes that's one of the three
reasons is that computational power
needed to do this at scale isn't today
becoming more economical than ever
before back then 30 years ago 30 years
ago only organizations like the army or
space organizations that had budgets to
buy super super computers could actually
do this now anybody can do this what
else that that is the key reason the key
reason is today we are able to get the
data that is needed to make this happen
the third reason is harder to guess but
if anybody wants to venture a guess of
the third reason okay we'll get to it
then we'll get to it so the first reason
is absolutely what you said is today we
are more sophisticated than ever in
terms of our ability to collect data not
just from the machines and and the stuff
happening in the online world but from
the offline world as well because of
sensor networks mobile devices
satellites cameras we are able to
collect data about everything and I'll
give you many a couple of examples later
on from our customers actually of how
they're using this now one of the
examples I really like to use is the ATM
machine example when you went to take
money out of an ATM machine 20 years ago
you would put in your ATM card you put
in the pin number and the only
information that was captured was person
X a time
he took out Y dollars from account
number Z that was it we call a
structured data today when you go to an
ATM machine to take out money from the
ATM machine there is a camera in the ATM
machine taking a picture of your face
the touchscreen on the ATM machine has
sensors that measure how you move your
hand and how you move your hand is a
biometric signature that can be used to
identify you the cell phone if it has
the app for the bank then we know we
were standing right there in front of
the ATM machine so in addition to this
very small piece of information person X
time T Y dollars account see we have
this mountain of information and that's
what we call big data that allows us to
truly tell who is standing right there
in front of that ATM machine and whether
this is a fraud transaction or an actual
transaction so now today we joke and we
say the only people able to steal money
from your ATM account are Mission
Impossible people because they need to
copy your face and copy your phone and
all of these kind of things though I was
in a trip in Malaysia about two months
ago and I was talking to the Malaysians
about how ATM machines now become much
harder to penetrate because of all of
this big data and AI facial detection
and so on and they said we have a much
bigger problem you're hoping you can
help us with and I told them what's your
problem and they said our thieves they
come in and they come use a bulldozer
and they just take the whole ATM machine
somewhere else and open it up and take
the money from inside it and of course I
told them that's not a big data problem
that's a much harder fault that we can
deal with but the number one reason why
this is happening today is we have the
data today we did not have the data it
was very hard to get the data in the
past today we can get the data much more
efficiently you can see some statistics
here like 90% of the data that we have
in the world today was generated within
the last two years 90% and that's
because within the last two years that's
when our sophistication with sensor
networks with mobile devices just
exploded in terms Batman and Batman
and we're only leveraging a half a
percent of the data effectively today
and the growth trend is really expected
to continue in the next four years going
up from 4.4 to 44 zettabytes
so the number one reason number two it
reason which you guys also identified
correctly is
the abundance of scalable computation is
today we have the storage the memory
subsystems the CPU and GPU subsystems
the scalable cloud architectures that
allow us and allow any company to do
this at scale and then the number of
three reason is open source allowed us
to democratize the advanced algorithm
algorithms needed to do this at scale so
this started with Google back in 2004
Google published these two papers called
MapReduce and the Google file system
which were the foundation of how to
start to do scalable computation using
commodity hardware and Yahoo to that
credit and to Google's credit as well
but yeah how to years later they took
the concepts from these papers and they
implemented them into open source which
gave us this give us the birth of Hadoop
and this Big Data Platform in 2006 we
only had these two things HDFS and
MapReduce but they were open source they
were being developed in the open source
community with collaboration from many
many companies including ours and then
if you look what happened over the next
ten years is this massive innovation
people building other systems on top of
these systems borrowing ideas from them
leveraging them in new ways and that
created this very very rich rich
ecosystem of software and tools and
programs that allow any company today to
go and build these super advanced
machine learning and AI algorithms so
really the answers the question I post
you at the beginning is this is
happening today because of the
combination of three factors the first
one is the data is available the second
one is computation is available and then
the third one is the algorithms are more
available than ever before so what do we
do at Cloudera cloudera we take all of
this open source goodness that's out
there and we package it in a very easy
to use fast secure platform that our
customers can deploy within their
organizations to solve these problems
using machine learning and AI let's see
what we do at the company you can think
about us as very similar to Red Hat for
Linux so Red Hat they take Linux and
they make it more usable for the
enterprise we take all of this big
jungle of
open-source projects that you can see on
the far right there and we put them
together into a form factor a platform
that is easier to use by organizations
some of our customers uses on-premise
meaning inside of their own data centers
and some of our customers use in the
clouds on top of Amazon or Google or
otherwise and the key thing about this
platform is the ability to work with any
type of data whether that be structured
data there's an X at time T checkout Y
dollars from account Z or
semi-structured or unstructured data
like images social media etc and at any
volume and then do any type of analysis
one of the most common ways to analyze
data is a language called SQL sequel
sequel is a very powerful language but
there is so many problems that we have
today that cannot be solved by sequel
that need more than sequel and that's
what's special about our platform
compared to standard database systems as
our platform can work with any type of
data structured or unstructured at scale
and then can allow you to tackle that
data extract value from that data using
sequel or going beyond sequel if you
need to go beyond sequel so we have
another number of other frameworks that
cannot analyze data in your ways so now
I want to give you some examples to make
it more concrete what exactly do we do
and the first example is engine from the
insurance industry and before I talk
about that I want to talk about a hack a
trick that we many of us came up in
different industries to deal with the
fact that we could not scale we could
not scale our processing to millions of
users or millions of customers so we
came up with the trick that's called
segmentation so what is segmentation
segmentation says instead of going and
trying to target or model the behavior
of all of my 10 million customers I will
instead build a thousand segments
married with children married without
children this age group that age group
this income level that income level
living here living there and then I'm
trying to map fold all of these 10
million users into one of these segments
and then I do my targeting or my fraud
detection or my offers or my advertising
based on these segments and the problem
with this approach is that the good news
about this approach is it worked and it
helped us do this for many many years
but
the problem with it is at least to false
positives it will end up many many times
making wrong conclusions about specific
people by lumping them in segments that
they yes have the same characteristics
as a segment but they don't behave
anywhere like that segment so for
example in the internet age many 10
years ago 20 years ago before we did
proper segmentation and we use these
techniques of lumping everybody together
whenever I would go to browse the
Internet so I'm a male in the age range
of 40 to 50 years all of the ads I would
see would be golf ads and with all due
respect if you love golf golf is not my
sport I don't watch it I don't play it
in fact I almost hate golf
it's not my thing yet I would get golf
as all the time because I was folded
into that segment on the other hand my
son who is a teenager and loves video
games continuously gets video games ads
when I also love video games I play
video games all the time and I have to
go and ask him what it's ad that you
have seen here or Lily's ad you have
seen there because his age group was
being folded into the right segment he
was just lucky that that was happening
for him at the time so same thing in the
insurance industry in my house I am the
lowest monthly premium for car insurance
I play the lowest insurance per month
because I am a male in the age range
4050 my son is the highest insurance
premium in our house
because he is a teenager male which is
much worse than teenage females I guess
in terms of my daughter actually also
teenagers she has a lower premium than
he does and that is again incorrect and
a function of the segmentation because
if you look at my son's driving behavior
the actual behavior he's actually a much
safer driver than me
he's always careful very paranoid never
speeds up stops at the stoplights all
the time and I told you earlier that I
am from Egypt originally I don't know if
you have ever been to Cairo Egypt but in
Cairo Egypt when you're driving in the
street the stoplight is a hint you can
take that hint or you can go it's up to
you is it's not really enforced very
heavily speed limits are also hints so
my driving behavior is not as nice as my
son's driving behavior because of that
I'm still getting the lowest premium in
the house so what many companies are
doing now insurance industry across the
world actually is putting these devices
in the car that measure your actual
driving behavior how you speed up how
you slow down where you stop when you
stop when you take a turn left or turn
right are you using the signals when
you're driving on the highway are you
steady or are you wobbling all these
kinds of parameters and that is what is
used to compute your insurance premium
not your age or your your gender or your
income level or where you live it's now
more a function of actually how you do
and what's the probability of you having
an accident because of how you're
driving your actual behavior so that's a
very very big shift in many industries
not just the insurance industry we call
this the segment of 1 the segment of 1
so moving away from the segment of
everybody to create a segment for every
single customer for every single user
for every single patient every single
citizen so mentioning patients this is
another example of using data to give
voice for premature babies so premature
babies there when they are in neonatal
intensive care their brains have not
really fully formed yet so their neural
network that they have doesn't know when
to cry so sometimes they will cry when
they're happy and sometimes they will
not cry when they're very heavy
distressed which is a big problem for
the for the nurses and the doctors
trying to care for them so what our
customers have done in this case is they
built a predictive model that analyzes
the signals coming out of the body of
the baby how they move the sum of the
brainwaves the pressure the heart rate
the sounds they make and a screen would
show up on the monitor above the crib of
that baby saying what's going on like
the message will show up and say I'm too
distressed from the light in the room
right now is too high please lower the
light a little bit and the nurse would
go and lower the light or there's too
much noise right now in the room or I
need to be fed so a language words are
being now prescribed to them based on
the signals coming out of their body and
then this is a very standard example of
big data being used for doing one of the
most common use cases in big data that's
called anomaly
action anomaly detection or the unknown
unknowns or finding weird stuff
finding weird stuff so MasterCard is one
of our largest customers they have more
than 10 petabytes of data in their
warehouse and one of the most common
attacks that hackers do when they're
trying to steal money from credit cards
is take a very small amount like two
bucks three bucks to stay under the
radar because none of us really call
their company and when they say three
bucks but we if we notice 100 bucks we
will call them and by doing that over
many many credit cards it becomes very
hard for any individual or even any bank
what we would mastercard to catch it but
mastercard themselves because they have
the view of the full data set they are
now able to catch this very very
sophisticated under-the-radar
attacks using what's called anomaly
detection so that's a very quick flavor
of some of the use cases that we have in
our customer base but in summary and
because before I move on to the next
section which is about startups we at
Keller I strongly believe that there is
a data revolution going on right now
and this data revolution is as big if
not bigger than the Industrial
Revolution so in the Industrial
Revolution what we learned as
organizations and countries and
enterprises is how to start leveraging
machines steam engines and electrical
engines to make carpets and make chairs
and make stuff instead of using our
hands right and that allowed us to
significantly improve the speed the
volume the throughput of manufacturing
across the world and countries that were
able to leverage that and of that became
the leaders of the world and the same
thing is happening now with a data
revolution which is there is a lot of
sophistication being built out there
right now about how can we take data and
automate decision-making using data
versus having humans have to be in the
loop every time before decision can be
made and these decisions can be business
decisions at a very high level but they
call Sobe autonomous cars how we drive
at the car if you look at how we drive a
car that's really just about making a
decision what should I do exactly at
this right at this time and that will
transform the world in very significant
ways so that's kind of the motion the
market the movement that Caldera
trying to enable and now I'll move on
from that to entrepreneurship I just
wanna check how we're doing timewise so
we have until okay good so I'll keep my
eye on the clock so the club dress story
so far we have four founders in the
company I'm one of them so I came from
Yahoo Yahoo acquired my first company as
I told you earlier Mike Olson comes from
Oracle and both me and Mike are still
very heavily involved with caldera after
the day and that was eight years ago and
we sought the company there's two other
co-founders who are less involved today
Jeff hammer Becker from Facebook and
Krystal Basilio from Google we raised
our first round of funding round a five
million dollars by VC called accel
partners
accel partners this famous from being
the first VC behind Facebook is one of
their largest investments and we raised
that money in October 2008 that's when
the financial markets were falling
everywhere left and right because of the
mortgage crisis it was technically so we
were lucky at the beginning of our
journey we were very lucky that we
raised the money and we were still able
to raise that money and find an investor
that's willing to buy our pitch we only
had a PowerPoint presentation and the
four founders at the time telling them
that we think there is a massive data
revolution going to happen and is going
to be called big data there was no need
the name big didn't even exist back then
when we said this so we were fortunate
from that perspective but we started to
deliver we started to get liver results
start to have customers another VC came
and said we want to fund you a grail of
partners so we took another six million
a few months later actually it's not bad
it's like six seven eight months later
and then another one came later because
we kept doing well and the story just
kept going we today a cloud era raised
in total more than 1 billion dollars in
capital in the company that's not our
valuation that's how much money we
actually took as a company and we're
using that money to expand globally so
we proved that the business model works
in the US we proved how this can solve
problems for financial companies for
health companies for many texturing
companies for governments and now we're
scaling that across the world and when
you're scaling you need money to scale
actually especially in an enterprise
software so we now have more than 1500
employees
thirty countries across the world now
when you raise this much money and you
make so many rounds you're gonna hit
with what's called dilution and that's
what I want to talk about in this slide
so first show of hands in the room how
many of you know what dilution means the
word dilution means if you raise your
hand it's okay if you don't know I just
want to get a rough estimate so about
maybe thirty percent of the room raise
their hand
so dilution is the ownership you present
ownership of a company so you can see
this stage 1 and stage 2 as an example
here when you start a company at the
beginning ground 0 just like there's
nothing in the company other than you
and your co-founder you can you make up
this random thing called shares shares
is a random concept it's a myth that we
made up that lawyers are made up and
business and financial people made up to
signify your ownership in a company
right so we divide it's like you think
about the company is a real thing the
company is not of your thing the company
itself is a story and I'm it as well
but think about the company as a real
thing like a pie and then you're gonna
slice this pie into pieces and each one
is going to own a piece of the pie and
that piece is called the share and your
present ownership in this company is how
many pieces of pie you hold how many
shares you hold so you start the company
say at the beginning you're gonna make
10 million shares so you're going to cut
the company into 10 million pieces
you're going to give each one of the
founders or both of the founders
together 8 million pieces 4 million
pieces each one of them and then you're
going to set aside two million pieces
for new people they're gonna join your
company new employees they're gonna join
you so they get some ownership in the
company as well and at this time when
you're starting a ground zero every
single piece in the in the pie is really
worth nothing there's nothing yet the
company is still starting up we didn't
make anything so the actual value is
zero
it's very nominal so the way to think
about this if you're looking at this
slide is your angle your angle of
ownership you present ownership in the
pie is the number of shares that you
hold say in this case 4 million shares
divided by the total number of shares
that exist right now but that number
will change in the future so 4 million
divided by 10 million is 40% that's how
much you own that will be the angle the
value how much money you own which is
different than the number
yours is going to be a function of the
share price how much value we have per
share which is the radius right so the
more the radius the more value you have
when you're beginning the company at the
beginning you have nothing the radius is
zero so you own zero even if you have a
million shares ten million shares ten
million shares doesn't matter the value
is zero right now you go and start to
raise funding so say Stage two here you
went to raise money and you're talking
to investors and then Wester said we
will give you five million dollars but
we want 10 million shares in the company
right so you have to print 10 million
more shares this fake thing that the
ownership in the company the company now
we're gonna have 20 million shares
instead of 10 million print 10 million
more for us and we're going to give you
5 million dollars for them which means
that the value per share is 50 cents
which means the total value of the
company is what in this case 10 million
so the value of the company is 10
million because they gave you 5 million
for half the company so the other half
reasons to say that it's also worth half
a million so the total company is worth
10 million but now what happened is this
dilution effect I was telling you about
because now what happened is the
founders together instead of owning 80
percent which was 8 million shares out
of 10 million they now own only 40
percent which is 4 million 8 million
shares still but the 8 million shares
now are out of 20 million because we
printed more shares and that's what
that's what happens every time cloud
that I went to is more money we printed
more shares we printed more shares in
the company so my ownership in cloud era
I started with an R shape this big and I
kept shrinking shrinking shrinking
shrinking shrinking and it's a much
smaller ownership right now and some
entrepreneurs they freaked out about
that and say oh I'm losing all of my
value I'm losing no money you have to
keep in mind that you're always
comparing the percentage that you own as
a function of the area of the slice
you're getting yes at the beginning you
had a very big percentage but the radius
was zero it was worth noting now I have
a smaller percentage I'm not gonna tell
you exactly how much I own but let's say
own 5% of the company so 50 percent but
the radius is much bigger now the share
price we have is up from a few pennies
to now dollars tends to went to 10 20 30
$40
and the area of that slice is
proportional to the radius squared every
time you increase your radius by a
little bit your value goes up squared
compared to that the angle that you have
so it's a very long way of saying don't
obsess about dilution when you're
building a very big company your goal
should always be about value creation
how can I increase the value of this
company and increase the per share value
that's what you should focus on 100%
dilution is important you don't wanna go
and just give shares to anybody of
course you have to control it but but
don't be shy about doing it because
that's how you end up building a very
big company at least that was my story
at Cloudera
and it's holding out well it's playing
out well for us so now I have some
almost done this is my last slide though
this slide takes some time because it's
a it has lots of stuff on it it's some
of my advice that I'd like to give
lessons learned as I was building out
this company that I'd like to share with
with other potential entrepreneurs and
the first lesson is whatever you do make
sure that the idea the thing the mission
that your company is after is something
that you feel very passionately about if
you extremely passionately about and the
reason why is the analogy and announce a
funny analogy but the energy it's like
you're getting married you're getting
you're gonna be married to this thing
you're gonna be working with this thing
day in and day out actually more than
more time probably then you put in an
actual relationship and you're gonna
have ups and downs you're gonna have
many fights within the company gonna
have many problems you can have a
customer that's gonna cancel on you on
the last minutes you have an investor
that's gonna cancel in you on the last
minute there's going to be so many much
emotion and so much strife and the thing
that's going to keep you going over and
over and over again is the passion and
the belief that you have and what you're
trying to do and it's the same thing
that I think keeps a relationship a
marriage going as well is the passion
and the love that you have for the other
person despite all the bad things that
are happening so some companies go
through what's called the pivot a pivot
is when you change what you were doing
so you're doing this thing it didn't
work out so now we're going to do this
other thing if that happens and this
other thing is not something that you
feel passionate about you don't have
your full
art in then you should leave that
company you're not gonna survive it as a
founder you're not going to survive it
as an employee you might but as a
founder very hard because we carry a
much bigger load than an employee so
that's my number one advice by far and
in fact I do some angel investments
right now like I don't do a lot of my
investments but I do maybe a couple of
year and one of the key things I look in
the eyes of the intrapreneur I'm talking
with is are they do I see that the
passion jumping out of their eyes I do I
see this absolute love of the thing
they're trying to do and if I don't see
that they're not getting my money and I
think all the VC is actually they invest
in that way as well so it's very
important that you have that and be
genuine about it not don't take it you
can't fake it it's very hard to fake
passion number two and sometimes and
sometimes people find this controversial
you need to know how to hire great
people but more importantly you need to
know how to fire them very quickly as
well
when you're starting at the beginning
and you only have four people ten people
20 people up to maybe 100 even more
closer and I was 1500 so were past that
point but in this very early days of a
company of a startup you're competing
with massive other companies like we
were competing with IBM IBM has like an
army of people that can totally
obliterate us in any account we try and
and and attack and the only way you're
gonna win despite all these odds and
despite these bigger competitors is by
having amazing amazing people in that
founding team that sounding team needs
to be flawless in other words it's like
a sporting team playing football or
playing baseball or whatever everybody
needs to be playing and everybody needs
to be the best at the thing they're
doing and when you're a very young
startup as you will see in my next
bullet point you always have the sense
of urgency where you need to be moving
very quickly as well and and advancing
very quickly as well so you don't have
time to train people like some people
are good and I know if I were spend more
time with them I can change them I can
make them better but you don't have that
time you don't have that luxury of the
time when you're a small start-up so the
right thing to do is to let them go
right when you discover that one of the
employees and this very early team even
one of the co-founders is not really
playing at the same level that everybody
else is playing it's not putting the
same
not generating the same impact it's not
about time it's about impact or not
fitting from a cultural perspective
culture is very important as well then
it's time to make a change and it's very
hard to make a change but it has to be
done and that's what I think that's what
makes Silicon Valley's so special when
it comes to this compared to Europe or
many other Asia and many other countries
are trying to replicate the same thing
that we have here is our willingness to
do it but our willings also do it in a
very humane way in a very in a very
decent way like we take good care of
these people when we're letting them go
we have them find a new job we give them
some shares in the company still we give
them a big severance package etc etc but
it's important it's part of what you do
later on when you grow as a company and
you have say I would say more than 400
people then now the impact of any single
person divided by 400 is not read that
as big so now you can afford to spend
more time with them training them and
coaching them and getting them into a
good State so now today at Cloudera
when we are 1,500 we don't fire people
like that we take our time we do try and
make them better but when we when we
were very young when you only 10 people
or 20 people and one is not doing well
the impact is going to be felt by
everybody the whole company will slow
down and that's where you need to be
quicker about making Corrections this
lesson I'm sure you guys hear this over
and over again it's one of the core
ethos of a Silicon Valley and of startup
culture which is don't be afraid to make
mistakes right so we strongly encourage
a cloud era since day one all of our
employees to try to do things in new
ways and not be afraid to screw things
up just part of our culture and part of
almost every startup culture here in the
valley the key point is if we see the
same employee failing in the same exact
way over and over and over again that's
bad but let's code failure there's a big
difference between failure between
failing right so failing one time and
correcting and learning excellence we
love that continuous failure very bad
right and that's that it's very
important to know the difference between
these two concepts sense of urgency even
today a cloud there are 1,500 people we
thirty countries worldwide we're doing
very well revenues wise but we know that
there is
many competitors coming up behind us and
even when we were just five people that
was true even now 1500 people is true
and even if you look at big companies
like Amazon or Google it's still true
for them you always have to have the
sense of urgency right like the thing
that keeps you up at night is what's
gonna happen next from my competition
that might make them
leapfrog me and how can I stay ahead of
them that should never go away she'll
always have that sense of urgency listen
to your customers so I in the first five
years of color I ran engineering as well
now I focused mainly as the CTO so more
on the technical aspects
I don't really run engineering but when
I was running engineering I would always
tell our engineers you have to listen to
the customers and build backwards from
what the customer is asking for and they
would counter me back and say are you
telling us we cannot be innovative
you're telling us we cannot innovate we
always have to do what the customer is
asking that means we are not innovating
and and that's a fallacy that's a very
big mistake innovation is not about
innovating a new problem right if you
innovate a new problem that nobody has
nobody is going to buy the solution you
have for that problem
innovation is about innovating a new
solution to an existing problem
and the hard part that we have as
product designers and as engineers and
frankly the pitfall that we many of us
fall on when we go for a PhD and become
very heavy on the research side is we
lost this connection between did we
innovate the problem or is this problem
a real problem that people have and
before you start any significant effort
you want to make sure that the problem
is a real problem not one that you
invented and one of the famous quotes
that I like from Henry Ford Henry Ford
he didn't really invent the car he
invent the pipeline that allows us to
make assembly line allows us to make
cars efficiently but he's frequently
credited with inventing the cars and the
quote he said when I asked people what
they wanted they said we want faster
horses faster horses and this shows you
your job your job as an engineer as a
product designer as a company creator
and entrepreneur is not asking people
what they want right you always want to
go back and ask them what's your problem
what's the problem that you have and
they will tell you the problem I have is
I want to get from point A to point B
very quickly
and now you know okay now I'm gonna step
out from that think completely out of
the box all these perceptions about
horses and how we used to do things in
the past I'm going to forget them out
and I'm gonna come up with a new
innovative solution to solve that
problem and that's how you innovate so
never lose track of your customer and
which problem you try to do and never
invent the problem the failure that I
see many entrepreneurs get into is
sometimes they get so passionate which I
love but then they get so passionate
about a fake problem but only they have
but only a couple of their friends have
right and and that's obviously a very
big mistake to fall into have faith in
success so by this I'm saying positive
energy is very important I truly believe
that positive energy whatever that is
helps you increase the odds of success
for yourself and for your company you
guys must have heard the stat from other
people that talk to you only one out of
every 10 companies funded round a funded
not angel funded out of a Angel Fund is
even lower only one out of every ten
will do well two out of every ten will
do okay and the remaining seven will be
either loss for the investors and which
means nothing for the employees once
you're talking loss for investors you
mean nothing for employees and founders
or they will just shut down so in other
words the chances of success is really
10 percent for funded company that get
around a of investment and if you look
at company cloud or a cloud there are
now is and what's called a unicorn
category meaning we cost 1 billion
dollars in valuation the chances of
becoming that is 1 in 1,000 so it's even
much lower over every 1,000 companies
founded that have the potential to be a
unicorn only one will be so in other
words luck is very important luck is
very important because the other guys in
this other 999 companies they're also
all of them working their ass off
they're also all of them extremely smart
just like you are and what will make you
win is your luck
of course you'll execution and how good
you are but your luck will play a very
big part and the positive energy that
you have inside of your company so with
that actually also say if you are not a
religious person you have to wish for
luck all the time and luckily for us our
luck has been
if you are a religious person I usually
say ask your mom to pray for you because
you actually are gonna absolutely need
it to tell things in your favor as you
build out your company so with that said
these are some books that I highly
recommend you guys read they are very
good when it comes to spotting trends
and sponsoring what could be a a new
major opportunity but in general very
good advice for how to start a company
how to build a product that people
really care about they're gonna pay
money for and just how to manage people
and how to be good in life yourself like
the seven habits obviously it's a very
famous book about that and with that I
can open it up for questions how much
time do you have for questions we have
10 minutes for questions and we're not
gonna leave here for 10 minutes until
you ask questions first question is
there any specific industries there it's
a very good question so I'll repeat the
question do you think there is any
industries that are underutilizing
big data so right now we actually are
seeing all industries getting very
heavily involved in this space including
some ones that we did not expect at
Cloudera so for example we have
customers today in the farming industry
agriculture and farming I never thought
agriculture and farming will be using
big data but what happens is they have
these sensors in the field that measure
sunlight conditions irrigation levels
and the rate of growth of the crops that
cut the color changes and they you do a
lot of a be testing experiments to
maximize the yield out of their farms so
I wouldn't say there is any single
industry that's really not leveraging it
but some industries are better than
other in the speed at which they're
leveraging it so absolutely the the
faster-moving industry is now tend to be
the technology industry the financial
industry banks are very usually very
early adopters telecommunication so cell
phone companies and set for
manufacturers and governments to our to
our surprise governments are adopting
this technology very quickly both for
cybersecurity and terrorism but also for
tax collection tax collection tends to
be one of the things government's really
care about and this technology is very
good at catching tax evasion companies
trying to hide stuff to smuggle money
somewhere so lots of governments are
using it for that
all the way in the back I see you
channeling Jeff besos quite a bit in
your you know customer focus and all and
I'm curious when you're a very small
company with let's say almost no
customers how do you how do you try and
adopt this focus you know what what
problems do people have if you don't
really have people to focus on so the
question is how do you have this
customer focus when you're still a very
young company that has no customers to
focus on in the first place and that is
the hardest thing I mean that the
hardest stage of any company is that the
first stage of discovering what the heck
we're going to build and is this thing
we're building solving a real customer
problem that's the first stage the
second stage where you prove that you go
actually Unseld it and make money doing
that and then the third stage which is
the stage we are in right now is cloud
era is the scaling stage how do I take
that and scale so that first stage it's
trial and error I mean that that first
stage is you is usually where this 9 out
of 10 companies will fail is that fair
stage because first hopefully you have
some good intuition of you yourself
experiencing this problem so in our case
we were lucky that I experienced the
problems we were solving at Yahoo my
co-founders experienced them at Facebook
on Google but even before we had the
conviction even before we started cloud
era we still went out and we reached out
to people in some big banks and some big
telecommunication companies and we will
go sit down with them and we will not
tell them the solution we were thinking
of at all we would tell them what are
some of the problems you're seeing right
now and just listen and and do pattern
matching meaning are we say are we
hitting the same problems caused
instantly consistently over and over
again and that that was our approach
that was the approach that we took to
try and validate that the initial hunch
that we have is this problem that we
know is real because we experienced it
it's not just a problem for us and our
respective companies but it's problem is
bigger than us and yeah it's behooves
you to always try and do that research
before you kick off your company to make
sure that in at the metal level you are
solving the right problem to begin with
and then as you start to actually add
customers and have customers using you
then it becomes easier they're on to
always have these customer panels you do
once a month or once every three
quarters where you
listen to them and see what their needs
are other questions I will ask myself a
Peter question until you come up with
another question which is a question I
frequently get from students like
yourselves should we finish our degree
or drop out and start a company assuming
some of you might be interested in the
answer so if you look at myself I
actually dropped out with my PhD to
start my first company and then went
back and finish it finished finished it
PhD is different so PhD is a is a very
long investment and my advice today
actually to people is do not pursue a
PhD unless you absolutely want the PhD
for the pages sake in terms of your
career assuming you don't want to be
professor if you wanna be professor
obviously PC is the only ways you have
to go get a PhD but if you want a career
in the industry especially in computer
science and computer engineering you
will do way better in the markets if you
work right after the bachelors or
masters masters also does help but PhD
actually if you look at students that
start at the same time as you and you
you stayed for the PCE they start in the
market their career overall longer term
but the way back would fare will fare
way better than then you would so that's
when it comes to PhD programs and we
have been discussing earlier with Roger
that
yes he's seeing that demographic shift
happened here at Stanford when it comes
to bachelor's and master's I say
absolutely try to finish at least the
bachelor's degree and the reason why I
say that is what I said earlier is the
chances of success of a startup is one
out of ten in nine cases out of ten your
startup will fail let's lower odds than
many of the games you can play in Las
Vegas and not only that you will only
find out four years or five years of
your life after you invested whether it
works out or not so it's good to have a
bachelor's degree that you can fall on
as a back-up plan to go and work
somewhere well if if the startup did not
work so my advice always is yes please
do go finish your degree first to have
that backup plan in your pockets
other questions take a new question here
and then we'll come back to you Oh
computer science degrees what do you
think some of the majors are they're the
most valuable for careers at the moment
I did a science so data science meaning
statistics and operations research and
that kind of trajectory it's I mean it's
one of the most I would say even more
variable than science right now like
that the demand for these kind of people
that can program so they have some basic
programming principles under their belt
but they really understand math and and
and predictions and and statistics and
advanced machine learning kind of topics
way more needed as a scale right now so
I would if I can force my kids to go
towards some career it would be that I
know it's gonna be an amazing career in
the next 10 10 years yeah very good
question all the way in the back
thinking about like with PhDs and
research and stuff is it common that you
see people taking their HD research and
trying to spin off startup coming from
there because I know especially the tech
industry is much easier to do that and
under in other majors or other
industries and I was wondering on your
yes absolutely so I mean many many of
the great companies here in Silicon
Valley started because of that right
because of the PhD research triggering a
idea for a solution that would not have
been otherwise possible VMware is a very
good example of that Google itself
actually is a good example of that so so
I guess my answer the question is yes
other questions
you talk about how your day-to-day job
has changed from like each stage and
like talking about we're day-to-day so
the question is can you tell us about
your day-to-day job and how changed from
the first early days at Calvera to how
it is today so I'll start today and then
I'll go backwards today I'm the chief
technology officer for the company and
for an enterprise software company like
louder the chief technology officer 60%
of their time is about evangelism
so it's traveling across the world
talking with customers and at public
events about how this technology can
change their industry in very
significant ways so that they become
very attracted to the technology so I
sometimes joke and say CTO stands for
chief talking officer or also chief
travel officer I travel a lot I travel
I'm like last year I traveled like five
hundred thousand miles last year alone I
made the three loops around the earth
last year in the opposite direction so I
lost three days of my life
because of that you don't get them when
you cross the deadline this way you
don't get the day back so that's today
the remaining 30% of my time is about
the strategy of the company overall and
the culture of the company so as a
founder with my founder hat I still play
a very big role in setting the culture
of the company the type of people we
want to have working for us and then
from a strategy role are we building the
right things not for the next six months
but for the next five years that will
keep us alive so I think Gregg
Papadopoulos who was the I think he was
the CEO of some CTO of Sun was CEO of
Sun has this very famous quote he said
to give you the nagi of what a CTO does
versus the VP of engineering VP of
engineering doesn't implementation CTO
does that kind of division it's very
similar also the VP of Sales and the CFO
so if a company misses their forecasts
you don't blame the VP of Sales as much
as you blame that CFO that did not
project the math and the science that
they're going to miss their forecasts so
in the same sense if a company misses
the deadline for delivering a product
this quarter or next quarter yes you
blame the VP a vision engineer
but if the company builds the wrong
product for the next three years you
fire your CTO like the CTO is the one
that kind of supposed to own that and
make sure you're building the right
thing so that's kind of what I do today
and in fact I have a very long article
on this called what does a CEO do so if
you want to learn what the CTO does from
my perspective you can search for that
online and you will find it if I roll
back to four years ago I was mainly
playing the role of the VP of
engineering which is taking the
requirements from our product teams from
our customers and making sure we deliver
that on time and hiring all the smart
people that we have in the company
and if you rolled back eight years ago
when we were starting the company we're
doing everything right like like we I
was assembling the desks for people when
they come in I'll go buy from Ikea desk
and make the desk for them where I was
setting up their laptops with the
software they're gonna need to be able
to be productive in the company from
accounting and having QuickBooks to
manage the the salaries of people and
what we gonna do so it was really at the
beginning you're doing everything which
was fun but only for a short time and
now it's fun but in a different way so
that's kind of the trajectory of how how
it went and with that I would like to
thank you very much for for being here
today and hope this was useful and
informational for you thank you
[Applause]
you